we are at the women in entertainment
breakfast and there are so many
incredible women out there including
yourself how does it feel out is it
inspiring beyond words I mean yeah
beyond words for sure
um it's really exciting just to meet
people and be around people that I've
like looked up to and been inspired by
for so long I was particularly excited
to see Margot Robbie in real life and
she's just as beautiful did you have a
chance to say hey to her tell her you're
excited maybe for Barbie coming up I
mean I'm not gonna tell her that I'm
gonna admire her from afar and just yeah
stair
um but I am excited for Barbie
now I have to say you look incredible
and I love seeing your style evolve over
the years is this like the next
iteration of the next era for Addison
Ray I think the new era is being
confident and loving myself and not
being afraid to look good now you
probably think and no I'm gonna ask you
this question too there's a rumor that
you might be involved in Euphoria coming
up
what did you say about that I will say
that that's a rumor and we can manifest
that so so I'm sure a lot of people
would have interesting thoughts and
feelings about that but thank you that's
very nice I hope that's true I haven't
seen that anywhere but I think you'd be
amazing for it and I think you're right
let's manifest it let's put it on the
vision board for 2023 babe I'm coming
for you
[Music]